[Music]
the third season of True detective
follows a disturbing crime as it unfolds
over three different time periods from
1980 to 1990 to 2015 the present-day
period shows Maher Sheila Ali's
character detective Wayne Hayes as a 70
year old man who's still haunted by the
case while grappling with his own memory
loss ollie is wholly convincing in old
age thanks to the power of his
performance and the makeup artistry of
Emmy nominated prosthetic artist Mike
Moreno and your old man makeup Mike
Marino Mike Marino man is the best old
man makeup I've ever seen on any actor
we visited Mike at his studio in New
Jersey to find out how he turned Ollie
into an old man for true detective
[Music]
mike is the makeup designer behind Black
Swan wolf of wallstreet Birdman and
Heidi Klum's elaborate Halloween
costumes on true detective he was in
charge of the makeup and wigs seen on
Maher Saleh Ali and Stephen Dorff who
plays Wayans partner Rowland in the show
mike has a ton of experience adding
decades to actors faces but his
transformative work was really
spotlighted and true detective because
of the unconventional way that the
show's narrative was structured there
intercutting in-between time periods so
you really get a chance to see the
difference in the contrast between our
Chile's face and Stephen Dorff space the
first step in the transformation was
deciding where exactly the prosthetics
would go when you're designing a makeup
you have to find all these lines and
creases naturally that actor may have so
that when you glue pieces on to it it
doesn't move strange my herschel skin is
so perfect that there's no landmarks to
hide a wrinkle in or a hide a prosthetic
inside so it's really challenging
finding the place where prosthetics can
live next to actually make the
prosthetics you have to take a life cast
of the actor's face basically creating a
three-dimensional copy of it we start
out with a life cast of rehearsal oh I
take that life cast and I cast it out in
plaster and I take little pieces of clay
and I add a little where I feel is going
to look the best as far as wrinkles and
puffiness I add in wrinkles and I sculpt
everything down to very fine detail the
sculpture is run under water then the
pieces of clay are removed and put on
individual molds from which the
prosthetic pieces are made unsaid I take
those pieces in glue onto my herschel oh
and Stephen Dorff all these prosthetics
that were once sculptures once that is
done they're airbrushed to look like
real skin freckles
imperfections things like that once it's
all painted we glue wigs on make sure
the sheen and reflection of the skin is
really perfect it really took about
three hours to glue on the prosthetics
each day all that had to last throughout
a 12 to 16 hours shooting day it's a
battle each day maintaining the makeup
as well you know and I'm sure detective
we filmed in Arkansas in the summer so
it was really hot so it was also an
engineering feat to really kind of prep
their skin to not sweat put them in
air-conditioning tents put my Herschel
ax in a dark room where he's not in
sunlight and he's sweating Mike's work
on the show wasn't limited to the actors
faces his team also built a life-size
replica for will Purcell the missing boy
whose body Wayne finds in a cave at the
end of the first episode but the aging
transformations were his real
masterpiece you can see how they'd most
likely aged in real life as I try to
find on their own face where if I find
any little wrinkle or line or crease I
accentuate that I kind of a reverse
makeup artist makeup artist is taking
out all the flaws and things on
someone's face and I'm adding them in so
I'm really an actor's worst nightmare
[Music]